Minuten was sagen ich nehme an dass er
das was schon schriftlich verteilt wurde
dann hier noch mal darlegt dass
Deutschland eben die
lieferungsgenehmigung für die anderen
europäischen Partner erteilt und selber
zunächst mit 14 Leopard Panzern dabei
sein wird und ich habe die Möglichkeit
als Journalist heute hier zwei
Abgeordnete zu fragen das tue ich auch
gerne Ralf stiegner ist da im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss für die SPD und
Florian Hahn der verteilungspolitische
Sprecher der cdu/csu Herr Stedinger ähm
Frau stark Zimmermann in ihrer Fraktion
ja nicht gerade gut gelitten hat gesagt
das ist deutlich zu spät aber
unausweichlich gewesen wie sehen sie es
ich teile das Urteil nicht sondern wir
haben ja drei Ziele dass wir die Ukraine
aber Selbstverteidigung unterstützen
dass wir zum zweiten dafür sorgen dass
der Krieg begrenzt bleibt und wir nicht
Kriegsteilnehmer werden und zum dritten
dass wir uns abstimmen mit unserer
Verbündeten insbesondere auch jenseits
des Atlantischen Ozean sondern mit den
USA das ist gelungen das finde ich gut
unabhängig von der Frage dass ich selbst
ein bisschen skeptisch bin was das
liefern immer mehr schweren Waffen
Qualität aber dieser Teil ist gut und
all das was behauptet worden ist über
Zögerlichkeit und deutsche Isolation ist
großer Quatsch bei Entscheidungen von
Krieg und Frieden muss man das sehr
sorgfältig alles tun es hat der
Bundeskanzler gemacht haben in manche
nicht zugetraut auch in der eigenen
Koalition vermutlich nicht und dass er
so ausgegangen ist eine gute Sache Herr
Hahn sie sind der erste Abgeordnete habe
ich gehört der Fragen stellen darf
welche Frage werden Sie denn stellen
heute noch nicht oder jetzt noch nicht
verraten sondern das werden sie ja dann
in der Übertragung zeigen aber wir
werden natürlich noch mal nachfragen um
die Sache auch noch mal anzuschärfen
nämlich die Frage was tatsächlich wie
genau ist das eigentlich geplant erst
hieß es
die Anfragen von Bündnispartnern das
wird sozusagen abgearbeitet und dann
bewertet das würde ja ein Jahr und ein
Nein einschließen jetzt heißt es oder
hört man dass es heißt er wird sozusagen
Blankoscheck gegeben was denn nun müssen
wir mal alles sehen also Nachschärfen
aber grundsätzlich ist es so dass wir
als Union sehr leichter sind
Zeit dass der Bundeskanzler und dass die
SPD ihren Widerstand aufgegeben hat eine
breite Mehrheit des Bundestages war
tatsächlich schon seit Wochen und
Monaten bereit Leopard an die Ukraine zu
geben und es wird höchste Zeit die
Entscheidungen dauernd zu lange das ist
die Meinung von vielen im politischen
Berlin baut der Kanzler sich so viel
Zeit gelassen letzte Woche in Ramstein
wäre ja ein gutes Forum gewesen zu sagen
wir machen das jetzt so weil der
Bundeskanzler nicht die Bühne sucht und
nicht interessiert ist an flotten
Fernseher Auftritten in solchen
Interviews mit Sprüchen sondern weil die
Verantwortung hat am Ende werden die
Geschichtsbücher zeigen ob das Richtige
war oder nicht in die Bevölkerung
schätzt das sehr das sind Fragen von
Krieg und Frieden Gespräche zum Beispiel
mit dem französischen Präsidenten immer
amerikanischen Präsident außerhalb der
Öffentlichkeit stattfinden sorgfältig
stattfinden dass man das Ende bedenkt
sondern überlegt was kommt danach wir
hatten die Mörder Entscheidungen kaum
war die getroffen ging sofort die
Debatte das müssten eigentlich
Kampfpanzer sein wie geht das weiter
verkürzt das wirklich den Krieg oder
gibt es noch mehr kriegst und das
erfahren wie man stellen muss und dass
der Bundeskanzler so besonders handelt
über uns mit voller Rückendeckung der
SPD-Fraktion und großer Zustimmung der
Bevölkerung das finde ich ist richtig
und dann mögen Leute anders urteilen das
Lernen und das Schreien und das
versuchen zu drängen als er in social
media event dann reden die Leute auch
noch von freezy Leopards als ob das
Zootiere wären ist eine viel zu ernste
Angelegenheit um darüber so umzugehen
dass er das in Social Media erwähnt
stimmt so ernst der Kollege der gebe ich
Ihnen Recht den sterben tatsächlich
tagtäglich viele Menschen in der Ukraine
und Russland für diesen wirklich
erbarmungslosen Kampf gegen die Ukraine
und deswegen wäre es wichtig gewesen
dass diese Entscheidung schon viel
früher fällt die haben die Russische
Föderation hat sich jetzt regenerieren
können diese Regeneration haben wir da
Ukraine bisher verwehrt deswegen muss
sie das jetzt sehr schnell nachholen
wahrscheinlich schon während dann die
nächste Offensive der Russen sich
vollzieht insofern geht hier nicht um
sozusagen Social Media Diskussionen
sondern es geht tatsächlich ums nackt
überleben und deswegen höchste Zeit wir
haben schon viel viel viel Zeit
verblemmt darf ich sie doch aufmerksam
machen Herr Kollege dass wir gerade in
Ramstein Paket von über einer Milliarde
Hilfe für die Ukraine beschlossen haben
das Deutschland nach den Usern der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine
Overall ist und was militärische Führung
an angeht auch das Ergebnis
mehrfach Raketenwerfer all die Dinge die
sehr hilfreich gewesen sind die Kritik
an Deutschland wir sein zu langsam das
ist richtig großartig wir haben die die
ganze Zeit unterstützt die Waffen sind
sehr erfolgreich in der Luftverteidigung
sie haben jetzt eine Weile gesprochen
dass sie mich das mal ausführen und
deswegen ist die Behauptung Deutschland
auf der Bremse wirklich falsch und wenn
sie mal gucken die französische
Regierung äußert sich anders als die
polnische die im Wahlkampf ist also da
gibt's auch unterschiedliche Haltung und
keineswegs Deutschland auf der Bremse
sondern im Gegenteil wir helfen den
schwarzen Peter nicht unseren Partnern
zu schieben sondern fakt ist das Scholz
beispielsweise bei der Mördern massiv
auf der Bremse war letztes Jahr sagte
noch das würde zu einer massiven
Verschärfung des Konflikts in der
Ukraine führen deswegen keine Mörder in
die Ukraine dann wurden die Mörder
beschlossen dann hieß es nur Marder
Leopard jetzt Leopard wir sind ja froh
dass er sozusagen jetzt tatsächlich auf
der auf der richtigen Spur ist aber es
war unter anderem waren sie das und
andere in der SPD die das über Monate
verhindert haben ich denke das Schema
ist tatsächlich immer gleich denn diese
Leoparden wurden von der ukrainischen im
März vergangenen Jahres gefordert und
wir haben natürlich immer
scheibchenweise geliefert hätte man
nicht am Anfang des Krieges entscheiden
müssen unterstützen wir die Ukraine oder
tun wir es nicht und sie gehören zur
Partei Linken in der SPD die sich
natürlich finden muss Krieg als Option
der Politik ist immer ganz schlecht aber
ihr Parteivorsitzender war gerade einer
der letzten Politiker der gesagt hat die
Ukraine muss gewinnen eine andere Lösung
gibt es nicht wie soll die Ukraine
gewinnen wenn wir sie nicht unterstützen
Entschuldigung wie die SPD hat als
einzige Fraktion beschlossen
zugeschrieben ich habe damit gestimmt
bei der Entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben die Ukraine nicht nur politische
ökonomische Militär sondern auch
Militärs unterstützen und wir haben das
auch die ganze Zeit getan aber natürlich
hat die Ukraine Erfahrungen gestellt die
nicht erfüllt worden sind zum Beispiel
Flugzeugen die gewünscht worden sind
oder der Vize Außenminister spricht
jetzt davon es sollten Kampfschiffe und
Kampfflugzeuge eingesetzt werden die
Nato will sich nicht beteiligen wir
haben ja beides immer im Auge zu
behalten dass sie die Ukraine
unterstützen so gut wie das können bei
der Selbstverteidigung aber eben auch
dafür sorgen dass der Krieg begrenzt
weiß und die Bevölkerung will das
übrigens auch ich kenne kein Thema in
den letzten 30 Jahren wo man mehr
Zustimmung aus der Bevölkerung bekommt
die sich wünschen dass wir um sich die
sind eben nicht nur solche Sprüche
machen wenn es danach ginge immer gleich
alles zu machen was irgendjemand fordert
nebenbei bemerkt so wie sie das
Verteidigungsminister hinterlassen haben
nach 15 Jahren CDU Führung dort das ist
finde ich sehr billig Verantwortung
auszuüben nicht auf die öffentliche
Zustimmung immer gleich zu gucken
sondern sorgfältig zu beraten das
erwarten die Menschen im Bundeskanzler
genau das tut aber ja also ihre
Ministerin musste jetzt nach einem Jahr
schon die Segel streichen weil sie den
Laden so runtergefahren hat aber das
können wir nach vorne schauen sie sind
im Verteidigungsausschuss da war gerade
der neue Verteidigungsminister auch 14
Leopard Panzer muss ich jetzt nicht so
viel an das ist natürlich eine
Grundsatzentscheidung und das ist es ja
bei weitem nicht dort ist angekündigt
dass wahrscheinlich noch mehr Panzer
folgen müssen die Ukraine haben
mindestens 300 gefordert und was die
Menschen erschreckt ist es ist
vielleicht logisch aber erschreckt ist
das aus der Ukraine jetzt gesagt wird
wunderbar wir brauchen aber für die
Küste dringend Schiffe und eigentlich
wären Flugzeuge auch ganz schön wo hört
denn das auf naja Aussicht der Ukraine
hört sich natürlich da auf wenn sie den
Krieg gewonnen hat deswegen habe ich
Verständnis sage ich mal für Wünsche
aber klar ist jetzt ist der Weg offen
für Leopard die ersten 14 sind zugesagt
ich bin sicher dass es nicht das Ende
der veranstange und es wird jetzt
wichtig sein das was auch seit Monaten
diskutiert wurde nämlich das Deutschland
sozusagen
tatsächlich organisiert eine
leopard-flotte eine europäische für die
Ukraine das wird jetzt unsere Aufgabe
sein auch das haben wir seit Wochen
gefordert und Monaten aber es ist gut
das ist jetzt kommt zwei den Schulen die
eine sagt wie Lars Klingenberg jetzt
neues außenpolitisches Papier
vorgestellt wir müssen Sicherheit gegen
gegen Russland organisieren ganz klar
russland ist der Aggressor die anderen
sagen russland ist der Aggressor dennoch
hilft es nichts wir müssen mit den
Russen irgendwie klarkommen das ist ein
bisschen noch so dieses Anknüpfen an die
Branche Politik und vielleicht ist das
ja der Weg wie man eines Tages Frieden
kommt nur mit wem will man denn
anknüpfen im Moskau da höre ich ihn von
ihrem fraktionsvorsitzen immer
diplomatische geheime Kanäle gibt's da
genug Kanäle mit Menschen die Einfluss
haben auf Putin es geht ja gar nicht um
direkte Warnung auseinander das geht zum
Beispiel Union hat Kanzler stolz sehr
kritisiert als er nach Peking gereist
ist der Effekt war aber und bei beiden
war eine Woche später dann war das
genauso dass ich chinesische Präsidenten
erstmals öffentlich die großen Ordnung
rufen dann hört auf mit den
nuklearnungen russland hat womöglich
mehr Einfluss auf China hat womöglich
mehr Einfluss auf Russland als andere
das haben dass man solche Wege eben auch
sucht dass er mit den großen anderen
Staaten wie Indien Brasilien und
denjenigen redet die nicht mitgemacht
haben bei unseren Sanktionen dass sie
auch Druck ausüben auf Russland dass man
solche Dinge auch macht also
diplomatisch auch als nicht nur auf die
militärische Logik schaut das ist kluge
Politik dafür werden wir kritisiert von
der Union aber das zeigt eben da man
nicht weiß wie das ausgeht und man
trifft wahnsinnig viele neue
Militärexperten ich bin keiner ich traue
mir das Urteil nicht zu ich höre nur
dass auch amerikanische Generäle
zurückhalten sich äußern bei der Frage
was militärisch erreichbar ist mit der
Anzahl von Panzern aber jedenfalls muss
man das gesamte Arsenal haben dass man
sowohl diplomatisch als auch militärisch
hilft und nicht sich so verengtem denken
und in der Sprache und deswegen haben
wir dann das Fenster darüber aber wenn
es jetzt in der Frage gibt also dann ist
das eine Frage die Frage ist tatsächlich
sie haben es angesprochen die Frage ist
tatsächlich noch mal nach dem Ziel mit
den paar Panzern ist die Frage ob man
die Russen wirklich aus dem besetzten
Gebieten herausdringen kann dass
definieren ja viele als Ziel und ich
glaube auch eher selenski wäre durchaus
für zufrieden wenn man wenigstens die
Grenzen von Januar letzten Jahres wieder
herstellen würde das ist aber mit den
paar Panzern gar nicht zu machen also
ist ganz klar wir reden im nicht über 14
Leoparden die die Wände vorbeiführen
werden und die Russischen Föderation aus
dem Land werfen können dass es
sicherlich quatscht es braucht eine
ganze Menge das braucht weiter
Anstrengungen und der Kollege hat das ja
schon beschrieben es sind wir liefern ja
auch viele andere Dinge die dazu auch
notwendig sind aber wir dürfen nämlich
nachlassen wir dürfen nicht zögern wir
müssen da das jetzt konsequent
fortsetzen und das ist dann auch der
Punkt hoffentlich für uns der Putin dazu
bringt tatsächlich dass man
möglicherweise auch über einen Frieden
einen Vertrag wie auch immer reden kann
irgendwann auf den Bundeskanzlerin geht
ja auch gleich er hat immer gesagt
abgestimmt hat jetzt kann sich heute
hinstellen und hat gesagt seht her ich
habe es geschafft die Amerikaner werden
den Abrams liefern ich habe jetzt gerade
von einem Korrespondenten aus Amerika
gehört die ähm Militärs in Amerika sagen
völliger Unsinn der da ist ganz schwer
ganz schwer zu bedienen aber es scheint
ja mehr ein diplomatisches Zeichen des
amerikanische Präsidenten gewesen zu
sein Deutschland dazu unterstützen wie
lange wollen wie lange müssen wir uns
eigentlich noch an Amerikaner ankuscheln
stellen sich mal vor in zwei Jahren die
Waren in Amerika und da kommt eine
andere Administration dran oder ich
frage es mal anders hat Scholz
eigentlich Misstrauen gegen die
Amerikaner dass im Notfall die
nato-doktrin nicht greifen wenn die
Amerikaner vorher keine Panzer geschickt
hätten ganz im Gegenteil die Beziehung
von Joe Biden ist besser als es wirklich
seit Jahrzehnten wo ständig gewesen ist
zwischen Deutschland und Amerika und
natürlich müssen wir uns auf eigene
Verteidigung in die Hand nehmen können
nicht 80 Jahre haben seinen Weltkrieg
sagen sollen die Amerikaner von seiner
erledigen deswegen machen wir das ja mit
dem Sondervermögen hat Olaf Scholz
angestoßen aber dass sie die Amerikaner
brauchen und dass er mit den
Zusammenhang ist doch gar keine Frage
was sind die ganzen Leute die hier dolle
Interviews geben und glauben wir könnten
das alleine machen sollten mal eben mal
mit dem Franzosen das ankündigen das
Wetter großer Unsinn ich glaube oder
Scholz wird immer noch unterschätzt
gelegentlich und das Beispiel dass man
sich mit Amerika einigt zeigt ja auch
das war Kommunikation wichtig ist aber
dann noch wichtiger ist das vertrauliche
Gespräche hinter verschlossenen Türen
gibt mittleren mit immer nur dass man
sich verständigt am Ende und das was gut
daraus kam denn wir sind nur gemeinsam
stark wenn das Bündnis nicht
zusammenhält dann ist überhaupt nichts
möglich und das geschieht und das ist
auch das Verdienst des Bundeskanzlers
aber ist das nicht eine Schwäche auf der
Europäer zum Beispiel werden jetzt also
amerikanische Panzer vielleicht
geliefert leo ist jedenfalls und dann
liefern die Franzosen ihr Modell die die
Engländer den Challenger das sind ja
ganz unterschiedliche Waffensysteme das
macht es doch kompliziert für die
Ukraine die daran ausgebildet werden
solche verschiedenen Waffen zu lernen
also als allererstes würde ich mal sagen
wir sollten die Ukraine nicht
unterschätzen das haben wir im Grunde
schon von Beginn an das Krieges und sind
immer wieder überrascht welche
Kampfkraft sie tatsächlich entwickelt
haben und welchen Zusammenhalt und
Widerstandsfähigkeit im übrigen ist es
so dass das in jedem Krieg das Problem
ist dass es und ganz unterschiedliche
Waffensysteme gibt die man irgendwie
zusammenbringen muss das ist also auch
nicht so richtig neu aber es ist
natürlich ist es am Besten man hat eins
und die können miteinander kommunizieren
und deswegen kommt es eben so auf den
Leopard an deswegen war das ein
Schwerpunkt Diskussion in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten weil dieser
Kampfpanzer der erst am meisten
verfügbar ist tatsächlich in Europa und
deswegen zur Verfügung gestellt werden
muss was aber aus meiner Sicht für ihn
noch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt ist eins
ist auch klar wenn wir jetzt 14 Leopard
Panzer aus der Bundeswehr rausnehmen
dann Schwächen wir natürlich unsere
eigene Landes- und
bündnisverteidigungsfähigkeit und
deswegen musst du schnell wie möglich
nach beschafft werden und wir müssen uns
wirklich überlegen ob wir tatsächlich
die die die wehrtechnische Industrie
nicht auffordern ganz andere
Produktionsstraßen aufzubauen als wir
Sie aktuell haben um sozusagen das was
bei uns fehlt schnell nach liefern zu
können und um natürlich auch weiteres an
die Ukraine ranbringen zu können das
sagt ja auch der Bundeswehrverband seit
einem Jahr werden Waffen entnommen jetzt
noch sogar Panzer der kommt nichts mehr
nach der hat er völlig recht wir haben
die 100 Milliarden da sind erst 8
Milliarden abgeschlossen was läuft der
falsch
es läuft im falsch dass die
Bundesregierung bisher sich nicht an das
gehalten hat was wir eigentlich bei den
Verhandlungen um das Sondervermögen
vereinbart haben nämlich das
beispielsweise Beschaffung so
organisiert wird dass möglichst schnell
beschafft werden kann dass die 100
Milliarden schnell eingesetzt werden das
schnell Bestellungen ausgelöst werden
das ist alles nicht passiert ich habe
mit der Industrie mit Vertretern der
Industrie gesprochen die sagen sie
wundern sich das seit Monaten
beispielsweise beim Thema Munition nicht
eine Bestellung ausgelöst wird obwohl
wir jeden äh jeden Monat Tonnen an
Munition tatsächlich auch an die Ukraine
liefern hier muss der neue Minister
wirklich Nacharbeiten aber ich bin da
guter Hoffnung kann es nur besser machen
als seine Vorgängerinnen
noch ein bisschen weiter sie stellen ja
die erste Frage deswegen lasse ich sie
an der Stelle
da muss man dann schon Vergangenheit hin
oder her sagen wer sowas hinterlassen
hat dann beschaffungschaos im
vergleichen dafür wirklich 15 nach 16
Jahren zu Guttenberg Frau von der Leyen
und Herren alle die da tätig geworden
sind und kommt jetzt nach einem Jahr wo
wir im Krieg über einen Krieg mitten in
Europa haben und fängt an Kritik zu
überbeschaffungswesen also da muss ich
wirklich sagen da nennt er eine den
anderen eine Esel das ging auch ums
Volumen am 27 Februar der Kanzler eine
Zeitenwende verkündet auch für die SPD
denn die SPD hat sich ja jahrelang gegen
das 2% Ziel
gestimmt und jetzt hat er Vorsitzende in
seinem außenpolitischen Papier das noch
mal klar fixiert übrigens damals vom
verteilungsminister Peter Stucke nämlich
vom außenminister Steinmeier
unterschrieben das hat die SPD nie
gejuckt da in dieser Fraktion waren sie
lange ja und haben immer gesagt
unvorstellbar 2 % für die Verteilung
haben wir in einer anderen Welt geht
haben wir uns was vorgemacht was die
Ziele des Russland geht sehen das war
doch nicht nur mangeln das Geld bei der
Bundeswehr sondern auch teilweise
Mission Management beschaffungsaus keine
guten Verhältnisse was die Bürokratie
angeht muss man ehrlich sein und jetzt
der Rüstungsindustrie alle Wünschen von
den Augen abzulesen ist auch nicht die
richtige Lösung sondern das Parlament
wird sehr viel schärfer hingucken müssen
damit das effizient passiert und das
Sondervermögen noch mal vorstellen Olaf
als SPD das werden wir umsetzen so also
insofern sollten die nicht so viel
Kritik üben sondern ein bisschen sich in
Demut üben was das Thema angeht und dann
müssen zusammen dafür sorgen dass es
notwendige zur Verfügung gestellt wird
aber auch eins sagen weil sie das Thema
ansprechen wir werden nicht allgemeine
aufrüstungsrunden machen können wenn wir
das machen werden wir die Weltprobleme
nicht lösen von denen wir viele haben
vom Klimaschutz bis zum Wanderung
herzlichen Dank ich habe es gehört sie
auch meine Damen und Herren jetzt geht's
los mit der Befragung des Bundeskanzlers
ich gehe rein
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
wünsche Ihnen allen einen wunderschönen
Tag die Sitzung ist eröffnet
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
die Tagesordnung um die in der
zusatzpunkte-liste aufgeführten Punkte
zu erweitern von der Frist für den
Beginn der Beratung soll soweit
erforderlich abgewichen werden heute
folgt nach der Fragestunde auf Verlangen
der Fraktion der cdu/csu eine Aktuelle
Stunde zu dem Thema leopardblockade der
Bundesregierung beenden kein Vertrauen
bei Verbündeten verspielen
am Donnerstag ist vorgesehen nach
Tagesordnungspunkt 6 den
Tagesordnungspunkt 18 aufzurufen
Tagesordnungspunkt 7 sowie die weiteren
Punkte 11 und 13 der
cdu/csu-fraktion verschieben sich
entsprechend nach hinten wobei
Tagesordnungspunkt 7 mit einer
geänderten debattenzeit von 39 Minuten
und Tagesordnungspunkt 13 mit einer
neuen debattenzeit von nunmehr 26
Minuten beraten werden soll
Tagesordnungspunkt 15 wird abgesetzt am
Freitag beginnt die Sitzung aufgrund der
Sonderveranstaltung anlässlich des Tages
des Gedenkens an die Opfer des
Nationalsozialismus um 11 Uhr
als erster Punkt sollen dann in
verbundener Beratung mehrere Vorlagen
zur Reform des Wahlrechts mit einer
debattendauer von 68 Minuten aufgerufen
werden
weiter ist vorgesehen den
Tagesordnungspunkt 19 abzusetzen ich
mache schließlich noch auf zwei
Überweisungen im Anhang zur
zusatzpunkteliste aufmerksam ich höre
sehe keinen Widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
ich rufe nun auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
1 Befragung der Bundesregierung die
Bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt dass
heute der Bundeskanzler Herr Olaf Scholz
zur Verfügung steht Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben das Wort für ihre einleitenden
Ausführung
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Abgeordnete ich freue mich sehr dass ich
heute hier Ihre Fragen beantworten kann
und ich möchte gerne von der Möglichkeit
gebraucht machen am Anfang etwas zu
sagen kurz bevor ich hierher gekommen
bin habe ich noch mit dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski gesprochen mit ihm
die gegenwärtige Lage beraten aber auch
das was Deutschland tut und tun wird
meine Damen und Herren wenn man die
Sorgen und Berichte über das letzte Jahr
noch einmal zurück in Erinnerung ruft
dann wird man sicherlich sagen können
alle meisten haben gedacht das wird wohl
nicht klappen dass wenn Deutschland kein
gasaus Russland mehr bekommt wenn wir Öl
und Kohle komplett aus anderen Quellen
beziehen müssen dass das geht ohne eine
massive Wirtschaftskrise ohne
Versorgungsengpässe in dem jetzigen
Winter und ohne all die
Herausforderungen die damit verbunden
sind manche manche haben ja schon
gesprochen über einen wutherbst und ein
Wut Winter und ähnliche Dinge die unser
Land dann ereilen würden und mit denen
wir uns auseinandersetzen gehabt hätten
die Wahrheit ist dass es nicht
eingetreten wir sitzen hier es ist warm
und das ist doch überall in Deutschland
der Fall wir haben die Versorgung mit
Energie gewährleistet auch durch ein
ganz ganz neues deutschlandtempo mit
denen wir Infrastrukturen neu errichtet
haben und wir haben dafür Sorge getragen
dass wir auch die wirtschaftliche
Leistungskraft unseres Landes gehalten
haben und die hohen Preissteigerung für
Energie zum Beispiel ausgeglichen mit
entsprechenden milliardenschweren und
stückunterstützungs-
man kann also mit einem Kommentator
sagen die Bundesregierung hat die
Wirtschaftskrise abgepfiffen wir sind
jetzt in einer besseren Lage der heute
vorgestellte Jahreswirtschaftsbericht
hat das auch noch einmal ganz deutlich
gezeigt und man kann auch ganz deutlich
sagen wir haben auch gezeigt was in uns
steckt und das ist mir ganz wichtig denn
es ist ja doch in kürzester Zeit
geschehen dass wir alle notwendigen
Maßnahmen ergriffen haben von dem wieder
in Betriebnahme von Kohlekraftwerken der
Verlängerung der Nutzung der
Atomkraftwerke über die Füllung der
gastspeicher und viele
importmöglichkeiten für Gast oder
westeuropäische Hilfen und dann eben
neue Terminals an den norddeutschen
Küsten die ersten drei haben schon die
Schiffe mit denen das Gas importiert
werden kann
gewissermaßen gesehen und das ist ein
gutes Zeichen für Deutschland ich will
gerne an dieser
ich will gerne an dieser Stelle sagen
dass das Tempo dass wir hier gezeigt
haben ein Tempo sein muss das unser
ganzes Land prägt dass wir überall wo es
darum geht die Zukunft zu gewinnen mit
entsprechender Geschwindigkeit
Vorankommen zum Beispiel wenn wir jetzt
wo wir die Krise aktuell bekämpfen
mussten sehen wie schnell das geht dass
wir das auch machen wenn es darum geht
die erneuerbaren Energie Windkraft auf
hoher See an Land Solarenergie die
Stromnetze auszubauen wenn es darum geht
die Transformation der Industrie zu
begleiten damit tatsächlich gelingt was
wir uns vorgenommen haben das erste
CO2-neutral Wirtschaften der Industrie
Land der Welt zu sein als viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt voran zu
marschieren und zu zeigen das geht und
anderen damit auch den Mut zu machen
auch diesen Weg zu beschreiben
[Applaus]
vor allem haben wir den Zusammenhalt
nicht vergessen und den Respekt vor den
Bürgern und Bürgern mit all den
Leistungen die wir auf den Weg gebracht
haben meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren
Ursache für die Herausforderung die wir
zu bewältigen hatten was unsere eigene
Volkswirtschaft betrifft ist der
furchtbare imperialistische
Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine ein furchtbarer Krieg in dem die
Grundsätze auf die wir uns
jahrzehntelang in Europa verständigt
hatten in Frage gestellt worden sind die
Grundsätze die zum Beispiel diese
Aussage beinhaltet haben es darf nicht
mit Gewalt Grenzen verschoben werden es
dürfen Grenzen nicht mit Gewalt
verschoben werden das ist das was
Russland aufgekündigt hat das ist die
Zeitenwende von der hier in diesem
Bundestag gesprochen haben
und deshalb ist es richtig dass wir eng
abgestimmt mit unseren internationalen
Partnern die Ukraine unterstützen
finanziell mit humanitären Mitteln aber
eben auch mit Waffenlieferung das haben
wir in einem Bruch mit jahrzehntelanger
Staatspraxis in Deutschland getan und
mittlerweile kann man sagen in Europa
sind wir es und Großbritannien die die
meiste Unterstützung mit Waffen für die
Ukraine zur Verfügung stellen und wenn
man fortrechnet was wir alles schon für
Entscheidungen getroffen haben kann man
sagen Deutschland wird immer vorne an
sein wenn es darum geht die Ukraine zu
unterstützen wir sind das Land dass das
mit großer Energie und in großem Umfang
tut
dazu haben wir entschieden dass wir auch
schwere Waffen liefern die
Panzerhaubitze den mehrfach
Raketenwerfer was Artillerie betrifft
werden dem Flakpanzer Gepard zur
Verfügung gestellt und tun das weiter
ein modernes Luftabwehrsystem wie RST wo
gerade neue Flugkörper geliefert worden
sind und wir auch weitere Systeme
liefern werden das Patrick System wie
ich vor kurzem zusammen mit der
Regierung entschieden habe und das sind
alles Maßnahmen die dazu beitragen dass
die Ukraine sich verteidigen kann alle
diese Entscheidung haben wir im Einklang
und in enger Kooperation mit unseren
Verbündeten getroffen das ist der Grund
warum sie wirksam sind und warum wir sie
auch treffen konnten das ist das Prinzip
dass diese Regierung hat
und das werden wir weiter so halten wie
jüngst bei der Entscheidung zusammen mit
den USA Schützenpanzer zu liefern
Bradley die USA und wir mit unserem
Schützenpanzer Markt die Franzosen haben
zur gleichen Zeit spielpanzer
bereitgestellt man sieht enge
Kooperationen und Abstimmung ist das
Prinzip und es ist richtig denn es ist
wirklich Krieg in Europa nicht weit weg
von hier in Berlin findet der statt
gegen ein großes Land wie die Ukraine
und deshalb müssen wir bei allem was wir
tun immer ganz klarstellen dass wir das
Notwendige und das mögliche machen um
die Ukraine zu unterstützen dass wir
aber gleichzeitig eine Eskalation des
Krieges zu einem Krieg zwischen Russland
und der NATO verhindern und dieses
Prinzip werden wir auch weiterhin immer
beachten
dabei gibt es für diese Dinge keine
mathematischen Gewissheiten keiner kann
einem erklären wo genau die richtigen
und die falschen Entscheidungen sind und
deshalb ist es richtig und mit vollem
Absicht geschehen dass wir uns Stück für
Stück vorangearbeitet haben und dieses
Prinzip werden wir auch in Zukunft
weiter verfolgen es ist das einzige
Prinzip das in einer so gefährlichen
Angelegenheit Sicherheit auch für Europa
und Deutschland gewährleistet
und das gilt jetzt auch für die jüngste
Entscheidung die die Bundesregierung
getroffen hat wir werden der Ukraine
auch Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung stellen
vom Typ Leopard 2
das ist das Ergebnis intensiver Beratung
erneut mit unseren Verbündeten und
internationalen Partnern und ich will
ausdrücklich sagen es war richtig und es
ist richtig dass wir uns nicht haben
treiben lassen sondern dass wir auf
diese enge Kooperation in einer solchen
Angelegenheit setzen und sie auch
fortsetzen
[Applaus]
unser Ziel ist es rasch bei
panzerbataione zusammen mit unseren
Verbündeten bereitzustellen das gibt
viele Länder die gerne mitliefern wollen
und wir werden das koordinieren und sie
einbeziehen damit das Schritt für
Schritt auch möglich wird Deutschland
wird wie gesagt Leopard 2 A6 Panzer zur
Verfügung stellen wird Leopard 2 R6
Panzer zur Verfügung stellen die aus den
Beständen der Bundeswehr stammen und
wenn die weiterhin das machen werden wir
die ukrainischen Besatzung hier in
Deutschland ausbilden wir werden
Ausbildung gewährleisten Logistik
Munition und Wartung der Systeme und wie
gesagt den Partnerländern ermöglichen
dass sie liefern können meine Damen und
Herren das ist das richtige Prinzip es
geht hier um sehr wirksame Waffensysteme
und es ist richtig dass wir diese
Waffensysteme niemals alleine sondern
immer in enger Kooperation bereitstellen
ein Wort zum Schluss es gibt in diesem
Land viele Bürgerinnen und die sich
Sorgen machen auch angesichts einer
solchen Entscheidung und angesichts der
Dimensionen die diese Waffe mit sich
bringt und deshalb möchte ich diesen
Bürgern und Bürgern hier und an dieser
Stelle sagen vertrauen Sie mir vertrauen
Sie der Bundesregierung wir werden
weiter weil wir international abgestimmt
Handeln sicherstellen dass diese
Unterstützung möglich ist ohne dass die
Risiken für unser Land darüber in eine
falsche Richtung wachsen das ist warum
wir das so tun und so werden wir es auch
weitermachen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank für die einleitenden Worte
und Herr Bundeskanzler wenn sie mich
beim nächsten Mal als sitzungsleitende
Präsidentin auch begrüßen würde ich sehr
dankbar unbedingt
wir beginnen jetzt mit der Befragung des
Bundeskanzlers und das Wort hat zuerst
aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion Jürgen hart
Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben gestern über die Presse eine
Entscheidung bekannt gegeben da hätten
wir uns gewünscht dass das in Form einer
Regierungserklärung hier im Hause
erfolgt wäre wo man auch hätte darüber
debattieren können
aber seistum die Entscheidung war
richtig und auch der Kopf des
Bundeskanzlers ist rund damit die
Gedanken die Richtung ändern können
ich möchte an dieser Stelle aber darauf
hinweisen dass auf dem Weg zu dieser
Entscheidung einer erheblicher
Flurschaden entstanden ist und zwar noch
vor wenigen Tagen streitauer von der
Bühne mit Regierung aus dem Baltikum mit
Finnland die Polen haben noch gestern
eine bürokratische Antwort wird geprüft
bekommen auf Ihre Anfrage ob sie Panzer
liefern dürfen statt ein klares Ja der
französische Präsident macron hat in der
Rede in Lissabon wo sie beide ja
gesprochen haben gesagt man wird nicht
nur an den Entscheidungen gemessen die
man trifft sondern auch den an denen die
man nicht trifft das ist ein erheblicher
politischer Flurschaden der von
Deutschland entstanden ist wer trägt
dafür die Verantwortung
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage und auch für
die Gelegenheit noch einmal vertieft auf
das Thema einzugehen und das will ich
gerne tun ich bin vollständig anderer
Meinung abgesehen davon dass wir die
Entscheidung heute getroffen haben sie
heute bekannt gemacht haben und
unmittelbar danach habe ich die erste
Gelegenheit genutzt hier im Deutschen
Bundestag etwas dazu zu sagen weil es
uns alle bewegt und das ist auch richtig
so
aber ich will Ihnen sehr klar sagen wenn
wir ihren Ratschlägen folgen würden wäre
das eine Gefahr für die Sicherheit
Deutschlands
viele Bürgern und Bürger fürchten sich
davor dass in der Weise regiert wird wie
sie vorschlagen
es wäre ein Fehler ein schlimmer ein
schwerer Fehler in dieser Frage alleine
voranzugehen alleine zu marschieren es
ist notwendig dass man sich miteinander
abstimmt und es ist ganz klar dass nicht
die letzte Pressemitteilung und die
nächste Pressemitteilung der Kalender
sind nachdem wir uns richten sondern das
was wir in enger Abstimmung mit unseren
Freunden und Verbündeten erreichen
können so muss man vorgehen wenn man
Frieden und Sicherheit für Europa und
Deutschland gewährleisten will und der
Ukraine helfen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben davon
gesprochen dass wir mit unseren
Unterstützung der Ukraine keine
Provokation gegenüber Russland ergreifen
wollen um den Konflikt Russland NATO
nicht Herr bereiten was ist eigentlich
mehr an einer Provokation Kampfpanzer im
Mai zu liefern als Panzerhaubitzen und
was ist jetzt anders im Januar des
Jahres 2023 das ist jetzt keine
Provokation ist in Anführungsstrichen
als dass sie das ja angesehen haben
gegenüber einer Entscheidung die
vielleicht letztes Jahr gemeinsam mit
Partnern getroffen worden wäre der
Abgeordneter ich habe das Wort
Provokation nicht in den Mund genommen
wenn es eine Provokation gibt dann ist
es die der russischen Regierung mit
ihren imperialistischen Angriffskrieg
sie greifen die Ukraine an und sich
Territorium anzueignen
aber das will ich ganz klar sagen was
ist der Unterschied
wenn irgendjemand hier hingeht und
wirklich glaubt
das ist richtig wäre dass man hier nicht
Stück für Stück vorgehen muss dass man
rausfinden muss was geht dass man eng
mit an anderen abgestimmt handelt dass
man den ersten Schritt und den zweiten
Schritt und den dritten Schritt zur
richtigen Zeit tut dann wäre das nicht
gut für Frieden und Sicherheit in Europa
und deshalb sage ich wir werden haben
das nicht nur so gemacht eng abgestimmt
mit unseren besten Freunden und
Verbündeten wir werden es auch immer
weiter so machen
eine weitere Nachfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion von dem Kollegen Hahn
dank frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben vor fast einem Jahr die
Zeitenwende hier beschworen zu Recht und
sie haben angekündigt die Bundeswehr zu
unterstützen mit 100 Milliarden und mit
einem dauerhaften Haushalt von zwei
Prozent von dem Milliarden von den 100
Milliarden ist praktisch noch nichts
abgeflossen die 100 Milliarden schmelzen
in der Sonne von Inflation und von
Zinsen und die zwei Prozent sind weder
an einem aktuellen Haushalt noch in
einem Finanzplanung vorgesehen sie haben
außerdem gefordert vor kurzem dass
Deutschland Führungsrolle übernehmen
soll und wir die stärkste Armee in
Europa darstellen sollen ich frage mich
wann wollen Sie Ihr Wort tatsächlich
einhalten wie planen Sie tatsächlich
auch das was wir jetzt gerade abgegeben
haben zu Recht was wir begrüßen so
schnell wie möglich nach zu schaffen
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage zunächst mal
in der Tat ich bekenne mich zu dem was
wir was ich gesagt habe hier im
Deutschen Bundestag unmittelbar nach dem
Ausbruch des Krieges Russlands gegen die
Ukraine bekenne mich zu dem was wir
miteinander beschlossen haben
dass errichtungsgesetz macht eine klare
Vorgabe dass wir im Mittel der Jahre
zwei Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung für
die Verteidigung ausgeben wollen und ich
sage ich bekenne mich dazu ich möchte
das gewährleisten nicht nur in dieser
sondern auch allen folgenden
Legislaturperioden dass das das Prinzip
ist in dem das gilt und mit dem 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen haben wir die
Grundlage dafür diesen Farbwechsel auch
zu organisieren und zwar ohne uns von
lauten Rufen rechts und links davon
abbringen zu lassen die richtigen
Entscheidungen zu treffen was wir jetzt
brauchen sind konkrete Entscheidungen
für konkrete Systeme einige sind schon
getroffen was die nukleare Teilhabe
betrifft mit dem F35 auch was an
Transporthubschrauber betrifft andere
sind unmittelbar bevorstehend und es
sind dann immer sehr langfristige
Verträge mit Produktion die manchmal
über Jahre dauert bis sie dann
stattfindet mit Munition und Ersatzteile
Lieferung und wir müssen alle in den
letzten Jahrzehnten Praxis gewordenen
Fehler beseitigen die die
Verteidigungsminister der cdu/csu auf
den Weg gebracht haben denn dazu trägt
ja nicht nur die Halbierung der
Bundeswehr und die Abschaffung der
Wehrpflicht dazu zählt auch das größte
Sparprogramm für die Bundeswehr unter
einer Verantwortung von konservativen
Politikern dass jemals stattgefunden hat
und dazu gehört selbstverständlich dass
wir all die Fehler korrigieren keine
langfristigen Verträge keine Ersatzteile
in ausreichender
Vorrätigkeit keine laufende Produktion
keine Situation mit ausreichender
Munition die ständig nachproduziert wird
und diesen Fehler in der engen
Zusammenarbeit zwischen Verteidigung und
Bundeswehr den werden wir beseitigen
dann können Sie sich darauf verlassen
noch mal ein Appell an alle bitte die
Anfrage und Antwortzeiten
einzuhalten auch Sie
nächste Frage aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen von aneschka Brugger
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler es ist eine
richtige Entscheidung die das Kabinett
getroffen hat die Leopard-Panzer zu
liefern es ist vor allem eine
dringend gebotene Entscheidung wenn man
sich anschaut dass die unschuldigen
Menschen in der Ukraine nicht nur
tagtäglich unter den russischen
Kriegsverbrechen leiden sondern dass sie
fürchten müssen dass eine große massive
russische Großoffensive in den nächsten
Wochen kommt und mit
Luftverteidigungssystem aber eben auch
mit modernen Panzern leistet die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hier ein
dringend notwendigen Beitrag für den sie
auch die Breite Rückendeckung aus der
demokratischen Mittel dieses Hauses
haben wie wir ja den ganzen letzten
Wochen und Debatten hier entnehmen
können ich würde sie gerne fragen
weil ja auch viel darüber spekuliert
worden ist den Leopard A1 aus den
industriebeständen zu liefern das die
Entscheidung ist jetzt Leopard
zwei A6 aus Beständen der Bundeswehr
natürlich müssen wir diese Lücken
schnell schließen ich begrüße das sehr
es ist ein starkes Zeichen auch von den
Fähigkeiten her richtig was hat sie zu
dieser Entscheidung bewogen ja schönen
Dank für die Frage wir haben uns
entschieden das was dann wirksamen
Mitteln zur Verfügung steht auch
einzusetzen das übrigens auch sorgfältig
vorbereitet denn sowohl das was wir hier
heute entschieden haben als auch die
Meinungsbildung unserer Partner sind ja
jetzt seit einiger Zeit vorbereitet
worden und noch mal der Kalender solche
Entscheidungen in anderen Hauptstädten
richtet sich nicht nach irgendwelchen
Ereignissen die hier in Deutschland oder
anders wo stattfinden deshalb ist es gut
dass wir das geschafft haben und für uns
war die Wirksamkeit sehr wichtig und wir
werden jetzt versuchen möglichst mit
vielen zusammen das erste Bataillon auf
einem hohen kampfniveau zur Verfügung
stellen und dann werden wir versuchen
damit umzugehen wenn weitere allerdings
nur frühere Waffensysteme was den
Leopard betrifft zur Verfügung stellen
können so dass das insgesamt aber eine
große Wirksamkeit gestaltet
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank so richtig es ist dass diese sehr
schwerwiegenden Fragen die sich glaube
ich vom einfachen Abgeordneten bis zum
Bundeskanzler niemand einfach macht in
diesem Haus ist dass die öffentliche
Debatte eben sich sehr stark um die
Waffenlieferungen dreht aber wir dürfen
unsere Solidarität und unsere
Unterstützung mit der Ukraine ja nicht
allein auf die Frage von Waffenlieferung
und Waffensystem so wichtig und dringend
geboten sie auch sind reduzieren wo
sehen Sie die größten Bedarfe für die
Zukunft die die Menschen in der Ukraine
von uns von der Europäischen Union von
transatlantischen Bündnis auch hier
weiter brauchen
schönen Dank für die Frage und ich
stimme Ihnen vollständig zu wir werden
die Ukraine mit Waffen unterstützen
solange und so sehr das notwendig ist
und gleichzeitig werden wir alles dafür
tun dass wir auch finanziell und
humanitär die notwendige Hilfe
bereitstellen das haben wir auch in der
Vergangenheit getan das sind schon sehr
große Milliardensummen die Deutschland
im letzten Jahr mobilisiert hat und wir
werden diesen Weg auch weitergehen das
wichtigste ist jetzt die
Energieinfrastruktur zu sichern und
dafür zu sorgen dass angesichts des
Vorwahl das ist
unerträglichen und völlig absurden und
unakt verzeihlichen bombardieren von
ihnen Energie Infrastruktur durch
Russland wir das helfen das wieder
aufzubauen und mit unserer
Luftverteidigung möglichst viele dieser
Angriffe zurück zu schlagen ermöglichen
und gleichzeitig wird es darum gehen
dass wir jetzt schon anfangen uns die
Gedanken über den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine zu machen denn das ist doch was
wir hoffen dass dieser Krieg eines Tages
zu Ende geht dass die Ukraine Integrität
und Souveränität verteidigen kann aber
könnte es noch viele Jahre und
Jahrzehnte brauchen wo die
Weltgemeinschaft die Ukraine beim
Wiederaufbau unterstützen muss und dazu
haben wir alles auf den Weg gebracht
auch Konferenzen und Strukturen
etabliert damit das jetzt schon in den
Blick genommen wird
nächste Frage stellt petribuestron aus
der afd-fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kollegen sehr geehrter Kanzler sie
merken dass schon eine andere bedrückten
Stimmung hier im Saal das ist ein
historischer Tag
sie haben gerade die Fundamente der
deutschen Außenpolitik der
Nachkriegszeit über Bord geworfen
und die besondere Verantwortung
Deutschlands für die
Opfer des Zweiten Weltkrieges war
sinnstiftend für die junge
Bundesrepublik und hier ging es
natürlich in erster Linie um die sechs
Millionen jüdische Mitbürger aber auch
um die 20 Millionen Frauen Kinder und
Männer die in der Sowjetunion getötet
wurden
und ihre großen
sozialdemokratischen Vorgänger Helmut
Schmidt und Willy Brandt haben sich in
besonderer Weise für den Frieden für die
Versöhnung eingesetzt und Willy Brand
hat dafür sogar den Friedensnobelpreis
bekommen
und nie wieder Krieg keine Waffen in
Kriegsgebiete das waren die Fundamente
deutsche Außenpolitik der Nachkriegszeit
die und diese diese Fundamente
danke liebe Herr Kollege ich schließe
mich denn dem an auch nie wieder
Faschismus
und genau genau diese Fundamente sie
sind diese Debatte überhaupt nicht
würdig wenn Sie hier weiter so
rumbrüllen wirklich kann der Kollege
seine Frage stellen die müsste er jetzt
auch bald stellen wegen der Zeit
und ansonsten
Konzentration auf die Befragung liebe
Frau Präsidentin ich hoffe doch sehr
dass sie mir jetzt diese Zwischenrufe
nicht von meiner Zeit abziehen
naja sie werden jetzt lieber Kanzler sie
werden jetzt in die Geschichte eingehen
als der Kanzler der dieses Vermächtnis
mit Füßen getreten hat und Millionen der
Bürger in diesem Lande fragen sich was
ist der Grund dafür dass sie das getan
haben was ist der Grund dafür dass ihr
eigenes Wahlversprechen gebrochen haben
was ist der Grund dafür dass sie jetzt
gegen die Mehrheit der eigenen
Bevölkerung handeln
schönen Tag für Ihre Frage eine falls
Sie mit Hilfe für die Ukraine
argumentieren die 14
aber die 14 Panzer sind nicht
militärische Entscheidung
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage ich will sie
auch klar beantworten ja es ist ein
Bruch mit all den großen politischen
Errungenschaften für die gerade Willy
Brandt und Helmut Schmidt stehen das
Russland die Ukraine angegriffen hat
denn dann Ergebnis ihrer Politik die als
Entspannungspolitik bezeichnet wird
waren ja auch am Ende die Vereinbarung
über die KSZE und die OSZE gemeinsame
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
als Zielperspektive und dazu gehörten
zuletzt sogar sehr weitreichende
Aussagen zur Demokratie in den Staaten
aber ich konzentriere mich ja auch einen
anderen Aspekt dazu gehörte auch die
klare Aussage es wird nicht mit Gewalt
die Grenze verschoben die sich
historisch irgendwo ergeben hat
Russlands Angriffskrieg ist deshalb ein
imperialistischer Krieg weil er sagt ich
nutze meine macht und mich über das
Recht hinwegzusetzen ich habe irgendwo
in Geschichtsbüchern geblättert und
gesehen Grenzen waren mal anders
irgendwer spricht so ähnlich wie ich und
deshalb darf ich mit furchtbaren Bomben
Terror mit furchtbaren Waffeneinsatz ein
ganzes Land zerstören und angreifen um
mir davon was anzueignen das ist
Imperialismus das widerspricht den
Prinzipien für die will Land und Helmut
Schmidt standen und stehen
Herr bistron sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen ja ganz klar sie haben natürlich
Recht das ist ein Parallelismus genauso
wie die NATO-Erweiterung und es wäre die
im Sinne im Sinne von Willy Brandt und
Helmut Schmidt wäre auch die Zusagen
einzuhalten eben die NATO nicht
auszuweitern aber die Frage ist sie
haben in ihrer Rede gesagt Sie wollen
die Ukraine unterstützen solange es
notwendig ist wie definieren Sie das
konkret also wann was sind die
Kriegsziele wann wollen Sie Schluss
machen mit den Waffenlieferungen ja wir
haben am Anfang über 5000 Helme
gesprochen jetzt sind das mittlerweile
Panzer Flugzeuge also was muss erreicht
werden was wann ist Schluss damit
Flugzeuge sind es nicht ich weiß nicht
warum sie das jetzt aufgezählt haben
aber wenn sie da was sehen dann
berichten Sie mir das mal also um es
jetzt ganz klar zu sagen wir haben sehr
weitreichende Unterstützung zur
Verfügung gestellt und werden das tun
damit die Ukraine ihre Integrität und
Souveränität verteidigen kann das
Kriegsziel
das Kriegsziel Russlands ist klar nicht
einfach einen Teil des Territoriums
anzueignen und das ist eben etwas was
uns unterscheidet wir sind nicht der
Meinung dass irgendein Land das
Hinterhof eines anderen der Hinterhof
eines anderen ist wir sind nicht der
Meinung dass Russland sagen kann ihr
dürft hier nicht überall eigenes
staatsgeschehen entscheiden ihr dürft
keine Demokratie sein weil das gegen
meine Interessen verstößt und diese
imperiale Idee dass er in der Ukraine
mit regiert die ist ja das was ihn zu
diesem Krieg geführt hat und das werden
wir zurückzahlen das ist der Grund
unserer Unterstützung
nächste Frage stellt Dr Marie Agnes
Strack Zimmermann aus der FDP-Fraktion
Herr Bundeskanzler das war eine wirklich
gute Nachricht die heute auch bestätigt
wurde von ihnen dass die Bundesregierung
den Weg frei gemacht hat Leopard 2
Panzer an die Ukraine zu schicken es war
vor allen Dingen eine gute Nachricht für
die Menschen in der Ukraine die wie sie
ja gerade auch gesagt haben seit elf
Monaten geknechtet werden an der Stelle
erlauben Sie mir auch Herrn Pistorius
den neuen Verteidigungsminister herzlich
zu gratulieren wir hatten gerade
Gelegenheit uns im Ausschuss
auszutauschen
Herr Bundeskanzler sie sprachen gerade
zu Recht von einem breiten Bündnis
eingebettet wir als Deutsche in der
Europäischen Union aber auch Teil der
NATO vielleicht könnten Sie hier noch
mal ein bisschen konkretisieren wer an
der Stelle besonders mit uns
zusammenarbeitet wo es Länder gibt wo es
vielleicht noch Überzeugungsarbeit
benötigt wir haben ja sehr
unterschiedliche Länder in dem großen
Bündnis ich glaube das würde die Arbeit
auch in der Gemeinsamkeit in Zukunft
auch verbessern
schönen Dank für diese Frage zunächst
mal kann ich ja sagen dass man das was
wir machen aus der Vergangenheit
hochrechnen kann weil wir immer
konsequent und immer gleich gehandelt
haben alle wichtigen Entscheidungen was
jetzt besonders wirksame Waffen betrifft
etwa die Panzerhaubitze etwa der
mehrfach Raketenwerfer etwa die
Möglichkeit mit ihres t oder vor einiger
Zeit die Entscheidung zu Patriot und dem
Marder haben wir getroffen nachdem
unsere wichtigsten Bündnisse im Norden
Amerika bundespartner im Norden Amerikas
und hier in der Europäischen Union
entsprechend und ähnlich gehandelt haben
und so werden wir auch weiter vorgehen
und deshalb war es notwendig dass wir
Zeit investieren für eine koordinierte
Vorgehensweise die natürlich jeder für
sich und vor seiner Öffentlichkeit
erklären muss deshalb gestanden sie dass
ich den entsprechenden Aussagen anderer
hier nicht vorgreifen will aber sie
haben ja schon mitbekommen wir sind
nicht alleine und das ist das Prinzip
dass wir auch in der Zukunft weiter
gelten lassen werden ein Satz noch zur
Unterstützung durch viele andere das
wird jetzt ganz interessant werden
übrigens auch für diejenigen die sich
besonders hervorgetan haben in
öffentlichen Diskursen der deutschen
Innenpolitik teilzunehmen dass Hick
Rhodos Hick Seite heißt dass man auch
dann substanziell was beiträgt darum
werden wir uns bemühen
die
Bundesebene ja es war eine Frage wir
sind gemeinsam der Meinung dass es auch
das eine sehr gute Nachricht ist
Fragezeichen
dass wir im Bündnis sind und das eben
auch andere Partner uns anschließen in
den nächsten Monaten neben
wirtschaftlicher humanitärer militärisch
auch die Ukraine zu unterstützen
dazu haben wir immer alle ermuntert und
was jetzt die konkrete Situation
betrifft werden wir auch alle dazu in
die Lage versetzen nicht nur was das
einfachste ist und ja auch logisch aus
unserer eigenen Entscheidung folgt dass
wir ihn gestatten wenn sie solche
wirksamen Waffen auch zur Verfügung
haben sie zu liefern sondern dass wir
auch gesagt haben wir fühlen uns mit
verantwortlich das zusammenzustellen
dafür zu sorgen dass die Kräfte
gebündelt werden dass das klappt mit
Ersatzteilen Munition und der Ausbildung
in Deutschland
nächste Frage stellt aus der Fraktion
DIE LINKE Matthias W birkwald
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler gestanden
sie mir bitte einen Themenwechsel
jenseits des uns alle zu Recht
bewegenden russischen angriffskriegs auf
die Ukraine habe ich eine
rentenpolitische Frage zu einem Thema
das sehr viele Menschen in unserem Land
bewegt auch wenn es bei dieser Frage
nicht um Leben und Tod geht
Herr Bundeskanzler ich habe mit Freude
aber auch mit Verwunderung so wie viele
Millionen direkt Versicherte auch ihre
Aussage vom 1 September 2022 bei einem
Bürgerdialog in Essen vernommen dass sie
für das Problem der doppelverbeitragung
der Direktversicherungen und der
Betriebsrenten mit
Krankenkassenbeiträgen noch in dieser
Legislaturperiode und ich darf sie
zitieren eine irgendwie fiskalisch
mögliche Lösung Zitat Ende finden werden
deshalb im Namen von sechs Millionen
direktversicherungsgeschädigten bitte
ich sie nachdrücklich darum die ist hier
im Hohen Hause erneut zu bestätigen und
ich frage Sie höflich aber mit Nachdruck
zu welchem Zeitpunkt und vor allem in
welcher Form beabsichtigen Sie das
Problem nun endlich konkret lösen zu
wollen danke für die Frage in der Tat
ein Thema das viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger umtreibt deshalb finden sie das
ja auch in den Verständigung die wir zur
Regierungsbildung hier gefunden haben
unter den drei Regierungsparteien wieder
als Auftrag das ist allerdings kein
trivialer auf gesagt deshalb ist es so
dass noch hart darüber nachgedacht wird
wie man das konkret gestalten kann aber
das ist ja etwas dass wir uns auch
vorgenommen haben und Sie können sich
darauf verlassen wir werden auch mit
Lösungen arbeiten
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen das
freut mich danke für Ihre Antwort ich
will doch einmal nachfragen ob es denn
auch schon konkrete Schritte
beispielsweise Gespräche mit zuständigen
Ministern gibt wo man zumindest einen
Zeitplan erwarten kann und ob sie bei
ihren Überlegungen dann auch darüber
nachdenken die mehrfach vorbeitragung
sofort zu stoppen unter anderem auch als
finanzielle Entschädigung für die
Betroffenen in deren Verträge ja mit dem
Gesundheits modernisierungsgesetz
millionenfach eingegriffen worden ist
und eben auch in die Richtung Halbierung
der Beiträge von Kranken- und
Pflegeversicherung bei Betriebsrenten
und Direktversicherungen also eine
Beschränkung auf den Arbeitnehmeranteil
wie bei der gesetzlichen Rente ob sie
das in ihre Überlegungen einbeziehen die
Laufenden
Beitragszahler haben wir bereits in der
letzten Legislaturperiode wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere entsprechende
Verbesserung auf den Weg gebracht und
ich weiß deshalb aus der fachlichen
Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Thema als
ich noch das Finanzressort vertreten
habe dass das alles gar nicht so einfach
ist und deshalb haben wir uns zunächst
mal auf die Frage konzentriert was macht
man mit den aktuellen die Lösung ist
jetzt Gesetz geworden und für viele eine
Verbesserung und da haben wir natürlich
noch die Frage für die Vergangenheit und
die ist eben nicht so trivial
nächste Frage stellt aus der
SPD-Fraktion dr Nils Schmid
Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler zunächst
mal will ich glaube ich auch im Namen
von vielen hier im Haus sprechen und
Dank und Anerkennung aussprechen für
diese abgewogene Entscheidung zu
aktuellen Waffenlieferung herzlichen
Dank dass Sie das auch heute im
Deutschen Bundestag erläutert haben
sie haben deutlich gemacht dass die
Bundesregierung sich an ein paar wenigen
klaren Prinzipien orientiert wie man bei
dieser durchaus sensiblen Frage vorgeht
gemeinsam mit verbündeten und
verständiger Abwägung der Risiken und
natürlich mit voller so Unterstützung
für die Souveränität der Ukraine wir
haben leider in den letzten Tagen
zahlreiche Gerüchte lesen können über
die deutsch-amerikanischen Beziehungen
können Sie vielleicht einiges zu der
Abstimmung mit der amerikanischen
Regierung sagen natürlich nicht über
mögliche Waffenlieferung aber um
vielleicht der Deutsche Bundestag
mitzuteilen wie es tatsächlich um diese
Abstimmung steht
ja also schönen Dank für die Frage ich
kann Ihnen sagen dass die Beziehung
zwischen der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
USA auf einem so guten Niveau sind wie
wahrscheinlich schon ganz lange nicht
mehr ich empfinde
große große Übereinstimmung mit dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten die nicht für
einen sehr
fähigen sehr orientierten sehr
zielsicher handelnden Politiker halte
gerade was die internationale Politik
betrifft und was die Unterstützung der
transatlantischen Beziehungen und den
Wert auf das Wert legen auf eine gute
Zusammenarbeit mit Deutschland betrifft
ist das ein Präsident der ein wirklich
guter Partner ist
deshalb sind meine Gespräche mit dem
Präsidenten immer sehr freundlich und
dann habe ich in irgendwelchen Medien
Veröffentlichung was über Gespräche
gelesen die andere geführt haben das war
alles mehr oder weniger nicht mit der
Wirklichkeit vereinbaren aber die
Gespräche waren auch freundlich
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen Herr
Bundeskanzler der wichtigste Verbündete
Deutschlands innerhalb Europas ist
Frankreich es gibt eine enge Abstimmung
mit der französischen Regierung bei der
Unterstützung der Ukraine insbesondere
auch mit Blick auf den EU Beitritt es
gab ein deutsch-französische Ministerrat
am Wochenende können Sie was sagen was
mit der französischen Seite zur weiteren
Unterstützung der Ukraine vereinbart
worden ist wir haben natürlich über
diese Fragen gesprochen und sind uns
einig dass wir die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen werden mit all dem was
notwendig ist auch mit
finanziellen humanitären Mitteln und
Waffen sie haben ja schon gesehen dass
beim letzten Mal die Entscheidung im
gleich
quasi zum gleichen Zeitpunkt ist was
jetzt Deutschland USA mit Bradley und
Marder betrifft und dann den spielpanzer
der Franzosen und wir sind auch jetzt
verabredet hier gemeinsam zu agieren
nächste Frage stellt Robert fahle
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
mir geht es eigentlich um ein einziges
Problem noch nämlich
auf Twitter hat Herr Melnik gefordert
also ich zitiere wörtlich mit ihr
Genehmigung und nun liebe Verbündete
lasst uns eine starke Kampfjet Koalition
für die Ukraine auf die Beine stellen
mit F16 und F35 Eurofightern unter Natos
Raffaele und ich weiß nicht wie man das
nennt greifen Chats oder creepen Chats
und allem was ihr der Ukraine liefern
könnt und meine Frage ist einfach nur
wenn dann Forderungen auf Bodentruppen
kommt irgendwo muss dann ja Schluss sein
sondern es muss ja irgendwo mal die
Grenze erreicht sein wo man sagen kann
das gehört nicht mehr zur Unterstützung
einer Verteidigung und Frau bärburg hat
gestern in der Parlamentarischen
Versammlung des Europarats gesagt wir
kämpfen einen Krieg gegen Russland und
nicht gegeneinander und meine Bitte ist
einfach dass sie erläutern das kann ja
wohl niemals die und die Position dieser
gesamten Bundesregierung sein und ich
habe immer hinter ihnen gestanden wenn
sie Sachen rauszögern die nicht
unbedingt notwendig sind mehr will ich
nicht sagen aber Herr Falle die Zeit
okay vielen dank für die Frage ich will
aber sehr klar sagen unsere Prinzipien
sind so wie ich sie erläutert habe und
ja ja die Entscheidung die wir jetzt
gerade getroffen haben ist eine bei der
natürlich viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sich Sorgen machen und deshalb noch mal
was ich versucht habe mit meinem
eingangstatement zu sagen vertrauen Sie
der Regierung vertrauen Sie auch mir wir
werden uns weiterhin nicht von
öffentlichen Druck und von lautem Gerede
beeindrucken lassen wir werden
Entscheidungen treffen die immer so
abgewogen sind dass sie durch ihre
Einbindung in die Entscheidung unserer
internationalen Partner und Verbündete
auch aus Sicherheitsgründen für
Deutschland und Europa gut vertreten
werden können und nicht im Hinblick auf
ihre Wirkung für die Ukraine
dass es nicht um Kampfflugzeuge geht
habe ich ja sehr früh klargestellt und
macht das auch hier als diskutiert wurde
über Flugverbotszonen über der Ukraine
habe ich wie übrigens auch der
amerikanische Präsident gesagt das
werden wir nicht tun und an dieser
Haltung hat sich gar nichts geändert und
wird sich auch nichts ändern
und
Bodentruppen werden wir in keinem Fall
schicken ich habe gesagt es wird keine
direkte Beteiligung von Nato-Soldaten in
dem Ukraine Krieg geben das ist bisher
nicht der Fall und das wird auch in
Zukunft nicht der Fall sein darauf
können sich alle verlassen das ist von
Anfang an so gesagt worden nicht nur von
mir sondern auch vom amerikanischen
Präsidenten und zusammen sollte das ja
wohl ein gewichtiges Wort sein
möchten Sie noch eine Nachfrage stellen
oder okay dann gehe ich weiter in der
Liste vor nächste Frage stellt aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion DR Matthias Mittelberg
Präsidentin herzlichen Dank Herr
Bundeskanzler Themenwechsel wir wollen
uns mit einer Frage befassen die die
Glaubwürdigkeit des Bundeskanzlers
anbetrifft und da konkret den Fall
Warburg Bank der Finanzausschuss des
Bundestages hat einvernehmlich ziemlich
einvernehmlich jetzt ein Protokoll
freigegeben offengelegt das vorher unter
geheimverschluss war dieses Protokoll
gibt eine Aussage wieder die sie gemacht
haben vor dem Finanzausschuss im Jahr
2020 und es betrifft die Konstellation
Warburg sie haben damals sich konkret an
ein Treffen mit dem warburg-chef
olearius im November 2017 erinnern
können sie haben dieses Treffen
bestätigt sie haben auch bestätigt
ausdrücklich dass ihnen keine
Vorbereitung für dieses Treffen
vorgelegen habe
und sie haben weiter bestätigt dass es
um die Themen Sachstand bei
Finanzbehörde und Staatsanwaltschaft
gegangen sei ich frage Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler welche Erinnerung haben
sie heute an dieses konkrete Gespräch
mit Herrn olearius und an die drei
weiteren Gespräche die sie mit Herrn
olearius in dieser Angelegenheit in
diesem Zeitraum geführt haben schönen
Dank für Ihre Frage ich will
ehrlicherweise sagen dass jetzt ja schon
sehr viel dazu gefragt worden ist und
auch sehr viele Antworten geben konnte
dass viele Institutionen und Behörden
auch mit all diesen Fragen beschäftigt
worden sind und das Ergebnis ist immer
das gleiche der Vorwurf das ist eine
Beeinflussung durch die Regierung in
Hamburg gegeben habe hat sich nicht
erhärtet und zwar aus einem ganz
einfachen Grund weil da nichts dran ist
und ein Unterschied zwischen den
verschiedenen Aussagen kann nicht nur
ich nicht sondern auch sonst kaum jemand
ausmachen deshalb habe ich übrigens auch
sehr gerne dafür Veröffentlichung also
das einfamilie mit der Veröffentlichung
dieses Protokolls erklärt
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank Herr Bundeskanzler dass sie diese
Frage jetzt konkret gar nicht
beantwortet haben
aber gut ich fahre dann mal
folgendermaßen fort wir haben
festgestellt sie haben vier Gespräche in
dem in dem relevanten Zeitraum innerhalb
von 15 Monaten vier Gespräche mit Herrn
olearius geführt dreimal Gespräch in
denen sie sich unmittelbar begegnet sind
etwa jeweils eine Stunde in ihrem
Amtszimmer damals als Hamburger
Bürgermeister dann haben sie von sich
aus noch einmal Herrn olearius hinterher
telefoniert um ihn mitzuteilen dass er
seine Unterlagen bitte an Herrn
schenscher weitergeben müssen sie haben
eben gesagt sie wollten keinen Einfluss
nehmen das finde ich sehr
nachvollziehbar wir fragen uns doch dann
aber alle wenn man gar keinen Einfluss
nehmen will dann trifft man sich
vielleicht einmal mit jemand oder ruft
ihn einmal an dann sagt man ihm tut mir
leid ich kann da keinen Einfluss nehmen
habe bitte Verständnis dafür dann trinkt
man vielleicht noch einen Kaffee
zusammen und dann auseinander warum
können Sie uns das erklären haben sie
sich dreimal mit Herrn olearius in
dieser Angelegenheit getroffen in dieser
Angelegenheit mit ihm gesprochen warum
haben sie ihm dann noch hinterher
telefoniert und haben ihm die Empfehlung
gegeben er möge seine Unterlagen an
Herrn schenscher schicken der sich
wahrscheinlich auch nicht einmischen
wollte in dieser Angelegenheit warum
dann diese vier Gespräche wenn sie sich
gar nicht einmischen wollten schönen
Dank für Ihre Frage vor allem weil die
schon tausendmal beantwortet worden sind
und im Wesentlichen sich ja alle ihre
Erkenntnisse aus Protokollen
tagebucheintragung von dem benannten
Banker Speisen ich habe alles dazu
gesagt und will das noch mal sagen mit
verdachtsfragen die etwas suggerieren
sollte man sowieso vorsichtig sein aber
wenn man nachdem sich alles mehrfach als
heiße Luft erwiesen hat immer noch
weitermacht sollte man den Zeitpunkt
finden wo man damit mal aufhört alles
hat sich nicht erwiesen
[Applaus]
sie dürfen noch eine weitere Nachfrage
stellen
frau Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler
bei cumex haben kriminelle den
Steuerzahler um Milliarden Euro betrogen
insofern geht es hier nicht um eine
Kleinigkeit und sie wussten Herr
Bundeskanzler das cum-ex illegal ist
sind nicht grundsätzliche Zweifel an
ihre Amtsführung angebracht denn sie
treffen sich persönlich mehrfach mit
einer Person von der sie wissen dass
gegen sie wegen schwerer
Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt wird und
wieso haben sie diese persönlichen
Treffen überhaupt ermöglicht in ihrem
Amtszimmer
stundenlang teilweise unter vier Augen
und wieso haben sie keine Vermerke dazu
angefertigt dadurch entziehen sie
Regierungshandeln natürlich auch der
parlamentarischen Kontrolle
ich will ganz gerne noch mal wiederholen
was ich eben gesagt habe nach so vielen
Jahren so vielen Untersuchungen so
vielen Befragungen so vielen Fakten die
zur Tage getreten sind so vielen Tage
auch Einträgen die immer die gleiche
Auskünfte grundlage sind für alle Ehre
Fragen ist mal Schluss mit Verdacht
äußern der keine Erhärtung gefunden hat
es gibt für das was sie in simulieren
keinen einzigen Beweis das ist schon 100
mal festgestellt worden es steht ihm
frei dass noch 200 Jahre vorzusetzen
wenn sie dazu in der Lage sind aber es
macht keinen Sinn
nächste Frage aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Katrin Uhlig
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler im Herbst
haben sie eine richtlinienentscheidung
getroffen darin waren zwei
Gesetzentwürfe enthalten die den
Parlament bereits zugeleitet wurden und
ein ambitioniertes
Energieeffizienzgesetz wurde angekündigt
wann ist geplant dieses
Energieeffizienzgesetz im Kabinett zu
beraten beziehungsweise wann können wir
als Parlament damit rechnen dass uns
dieser Entwurf zugeleitet wird schönen
Dank für die Frage bald
mir persönlich ist auch wichtig dass wir
dazu einen guten Ergebnis kommen dafür
fühle ich mich persönlich verpflichtet
und die Arbeit zwischen den beteiligten
Ressorts ist im Gange sehr intensiv
sogar ich glaube auch dass wir da bald
gute Ergebnisse erzielen werden
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Dankeschön teilen Sie die Einschätzung
das Energieeffizienz ein zentraler Punkt
ist für die Versorgungssicherheit den
Klimaschutz und die Energiewende
ganz unbedingt das haben wir jetzt
gesehen in der letzten Jahr mit den
Gesetzen die wir zum Beispiel möglich
gemacht haben zu einem unbürokratischen
fühl Switch für viele Unternehmen ist es
ja in kürzester Zeit gelungen die
Abhängigkeit von Gast zu reduzieren und
manche haben dabei nicht nur
zurückgegriffen auf frühere Technologien
die noch im Haus waren sondern auch neue
eingesetzt ein guter Fortschritt und das
gleiche gilt für viele viele andere
Maßnahmen die Unternehmen ergriffen
haben aus vielen Gesprächen weiß ich
auch dass manche sich wenn sie sich mal
ans Thema Rang gemacht haben gewundert
haben über welches Ausmaß an Einsparung
sie bisher nicht welches Ausmaß
anspringen sie nicht ausgenutzt haben
und deshalb glaube ich brauchen wir als
Gesellschaft da richtig einen ganz
großen drive in der Sache das ist
hochwirtschaftlich hocheffizient und
deshalb ist dieser Gedanke einer den die
ganze Bundesregierung teilt
nächste Frage stellt aus der
afd-fraktion DR Bernd Baumann
der Bundeskanzler
viele Migranten in Deutschland
integrieren sich ja gut aber wir haben
nicht erst seit 2015 eine massive
Zuwanderung aus fremden Kulturkreisen
mit ganz anderen Frauenbildern
männerbildern Vorstellungen von Staat
und Gesellschaft
Migrationsforscher wie der
oxford-professor Collier sprechen von
deutlichen kulturdifferenzen das zeigt
sich nicht nur bei schrecklichen
Eskalation in Silvester Nächten
Präsident macron spricht deshalb nicht
von Parallelgesellschaften sondern von
kulturellen gegengesellschaften und das
alles passiert nicht nur in Berlin oder
Köln oder Duisburg überall in Europa
brennen immer wieder stattviertel ob in
Paris oder Marseille in London oder
Birmingham Amsterdam oder Rotterdam
Stockholm oder coppenhagen dass in die
Wiege um kann ja immer auch anders sein
aber es sind immer die gleichen
Migrantengruppen die gleichen
Herkunftsgebiete die gleichen
Integrationsprobleme die so verursacht
werden Herr Bundeskanzler ich sage sie
gibt es aus ihrer Sicht auch ethnisch
kulturelle Differenzen die einer
erfolgreichen Integration im Wege stehen
können
schönen Dank
nein nicht schönen Dank für Ihre Frage
ich will ihre Frage gerne beantworten
danke
Ihre Frage beinhaltet eine ganze Reihe
von Unterstellungen wo man gar nicht
weiß wo man jetzt anfangen soll um ihn
zu widersprechen deshalb will ich ganz
klar sagen aus meiner Sicht ist es so
dass die Demokratie und die offene
pluralistische Gesellschaft davon lebt
dass wir uns als Individuen betrachten
und begegnen dass wir von allen
verlangen dass sie sich an die Gesetze
halten und darauf bestehen dass sie auch
eingehalten werden und dass wir aber
nicht mit Pauschalurteilen von
Gruppenarbeiten wenn es darum geht uns
ganz konkret zu verhalten und zu den
konkreten Verhaltensweisen gehört dass
wir eine offene Gesellschaft sind dass
wir auch Unterschiede akzeptieren aber
keine Unterschiede wenn es darum geht
wie man miteinander umgeht in unserer
Gesellschaft keine Unterschiede wenn es
um die Einhaltung von Recht und Gesetz
geht da ist dann immer die Härte des
Gesetzes gefragt und das ist auch worauf
ich bestehe
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ich
weiß keine Antwort auf meine Frage aber
eine weitere Frage Herr Bundeskanzler es
gibt ein deutsches Staatsvolk das sind
alle Menschen mit deutscher
Staatsbürgerschaft denen die gleichen
Rechte und Pflichten zukommen und dass
sie auch gut so für ihre Vorgänger von
Adenauer bis Kohl von Brand bis Schmidt
gab es darüber hinaus noch etwas anderes
ein ethnisch kulturelles deutsches Volk
mit einer eigenen geschichtlichen
Identität ich frage den deutschen
Bundeskanzler gibt es aus ihrer Sicht
Jenseits rechtlicher Staatsbürgerschaft
und bloßer Sprachgemeinschaft gibt es
ethnisch kulturell ein deutsches Volk
ich will Ihnen gerne auf die Frage
antworten wir haben ein deutsches Volk
das besteht aus all denjenigen die die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft haben und
die Miteinander in unserer Demokratie
über die Zukunft entscheiden
ich will jetzt mit ihnen kein
geschichtseminar über unsere
Vergangenheit veranstalten wer alles bei
uns lebt und seit wann das der Fall ist
aber ich will den ausdrücklich sagen es
gibt etwas was uns verbindet und das
sind nämlich Überzeugungen die sehr wohl
auch hier in Deutschland gewachsen sind
ja richtigerweise zum Beispiel dass wir
alle gemeinsam egal wo wir geboren sind
oder unsere Eltern und Großeltern gerne
sehr fleißig sind dass wir uns gerne an
die Gesetze halten dass wir unsere
Nachbarn achten und dass wir auch eine
moderne demokratische Gesellschaft sein
wollen die offen ist für das Miteinander
und unterschiedliche Lebensperspektiven
und dafür steht dieses Land und dieses
Volk
nächste Frage stellt Bernd Reuter aus
der FDP-Fraktion
Frau vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben in Ihrem
eingangstatement von mehr Tempo für
unser Land gesprochen und das Thema
planungsbeschleunigung ist ja auch im
Koalitionsvertrag prominent verankert
deswegen möchte ich sie gerne fragen
welche zentralen Maßnahmen wird die
Bundesregierung vorlegen um das Thema
planungsbeschleunigung umzusetzen und
gelten dann diese vorgelegten Maßnahmen
für alle Infrastrukturbereiche
gleichermaßen
schönen Dank für die Frage ich habe sehr
bewusst in meiner eingangsrede gesagt
dass die
neue Geschwindigkeit für unser Land
zentral ist dafür dass wir die große
modernisierungsaufgabe bewältigen die
vor uns liegt und deshalb müssen wir
insgesamt zu einer Beschleunigung kommen
dafür setze ich mich auch ein dass man
das sehen kann dass wir das machen ist
ja eine gute Grundlage für das was jetzt
ansteht im letzten Jahr haben wir mit
denen was den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien betrifft Frühjahrs und
sommerpaketen die notwendigen
Entscheidungen getroffen wir haben im
letzten Jahr auch weitere
planungsbeschleunigende Maßnahmen auf
den Weg gebracht gerade wird verhandelt
im Deutschen Bundestag eine Reform der
Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung die auch
diese Verfahren beschleunigen soll und
wir sind jetzt dabei konkret dafür Sorge
zu tragen dass wir alle Fortschritte
möglich machen die erforderlich sind um
die von uns selber gewünschte
europäische Richtlinien umzusetzen die
im raumordnungsbereich auch beschle
Bewegung vorsieht und wir wollen
generell etwa auch wenn es um
Verkehrsleistungen betrifft auch zu
weiteren Beschleunigungen kommen da sind
wir auch hart dran dazu einem
gemeinsamen Ergebnis zu kommen es wird
das große Thema dieser Legislaturperiode
das Deutschland schneller wird und dass
wir den Herausforderungen unserer
Zukunft gewachsen sind
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja
vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler können
Sie in etwa sagen wann die
Bundesregierung dieses Paket vorlegen
wird wir werden noch viele einzelne
Maßnahmen und deshalb nicht vor allem
ein einzelnes Paket vorlegen viele
einzelmaßen auf den Weg machen und
bringen und damit auch nicht aufhören
und die Antwort die ich vorhin einer
Kollegin gegeben hat kann ich auch ihnen
geben bald
nächste Frage stellt aus der Fraktion
DIE LINKE Susanne ferschl
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler die Tarifbindung in
Deutschland ist in freien Fall
mittlerweile ist nur noch jeder zweite
Beschäftigte unter dem Schutz eines
Tarifvertrages und eine Richtlinie der
EU schreibt jetzt den nationalen Staaten
vor man in den Maßnahmenplan zu
ergreifen wenn die Tarifbindung unter
80% liegt das ist bei uns der Fall und
ich frag sie stimmen Sie mit mir überein
dass Tarifverträge die Basis für gute
Arbeit in unserem Land sind und welche
Maßnahmen abgesehen von dem bereits
angekündigten bundestarifreie Gesetz
wollen sie ergreifen um die Tarifbindung
wieder nach oben zu bekommen zunächst
mal stimme ich sehr mit ihnen über einen
dass es wichtig ist dass wir viele
Tarifverträge haben die sind prägend für
das Sozialmodell der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ich bekenne mich sehr
bewusst zu der sozialpartnerschaftlichen
Traditionen unseres Landes und diese
sozialpartnerschaftliche Tradition
beinhaltet natürlich sehr genau auch das
Tarifverträge das Miteinander am
Arbeitsplatz Regeln und ich wünsche mir
dass wir wieder mehr dafür gewinnen mit
verschiedenen Regelungen Gesetzen die
wir auch schon zuletzt durchgesetzt
haben und Perspektiven die wir für die
Zukunft uns vorgenommen haben wollen wir
das unterstützen Tariftreue ist einer
der Punkte den sie selbst erwähnt haben
natürlich geht das nicht mit Zwang man
muss dafür sorgen dass Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer sich zusammentun um
Tarifverträge zu verlangen und wir
müssen ihnen dabei helfen dass sie dabei
nicht ungerecht behindert werden und wir
müssen dafür Sorge tragen dass das auch
erfolgreich wird mit den Tarifverträgen
ich bin wie Sie wissen in meinem Beruf
bevor ich Abgeordneter des Deutschen
Bundestages im Jahre 1998 geworden war
arbeitsrechtsanwalt gewesen habe viele
betriebsräte und Gewerkschaften
vertreten auch viele einzelne
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
deshalb ist der Wunsch nach mehr und
leistungsfähigen Tarifverträgen eine der
mir ganz wichtig ist
ich grüße Sie herzlich und Frage möchten
Sie noch eine Nachfrage stellen
bitteschön vielen Dank ich freue mich
auch dass wir so eine große
Übereinstimmung an dem Punkt haben der
Bundeskanzler aber beim der Leiharbeit
wird dieses System ein Stück weit
Adaptionen geführt weil schlechte
Arbeitsbedingungen und Ausbeutung
möglich sind durch eine Öffnung
Öffnungsklauseln die gesetzlich durch
die große Koalition möglich gemacht
worden sind und ich frag sie wann wollen
Sie dieses Schlupfloch schließen damit
auch für Beschäftigte in der Leiharbeit
der Grundsatz gleiche Lohn für gleiche
Arbeit gilt wir haben sehr viele
Reformen der Leiharbeit in der
Vergangenheit vorgenommen genau um die
Schlupflöcher die sie aus vergangener
Zeit beschreiben zu beseitigen und
werden uns das auch weiterhin immer sehr
genau angucken aber das will ich Ihnen
schon sagen die Grundlage für das was an
Handlungsmöglichkeiten besteht sind
immer allgemein akzeptierbare
Tarifverträge und das ist auch die
Grundlage dafür dass wir eine Leiharbeit
mehr Tarifbindung bekommen haben als das
früher der Fall war denn die sind
dadurch sehr gestaltend in dem Bereich
und das ist auch mein Wunsch
die nächste Frage kommt vom Kollegen
timoshibanowski
schisanowski korrekt herzlichen Dank
Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrter
Bundeskanzler die Bundesregierung hat
sich richtigerweise ja zum Ziel gesetzt
Deutschland umfassend zu modernisieren
damit wir auch in 20 in 30 Jahren
erfolgreich sind und
entscheidender Faktor ist ja eine unsere
intakte öffentliche Infrastruktur auch
der Zukunft und zum Jahresauftakt hat
sich deshalb ja auch fallen allen voran
die SPD für ein starkes Comeback eine
aktiven Infrastrukturpolitik für das 21
Jahrhundert ausgesprochen und deshalb in
diesem Zusammenhang meine Frage welche
Strategie und welche Maßnahmen für
Deutschland
Infrastrukturpolitik gedenkt die
Bundesregierung zu ergreifen
zunächst mal geht es darum dass wir wenn
es um öffentliche Infrastruktur geht die
Finanzmittel bereitstellen das haben wir
im großen Umfang getan und das wird auch
weiter trotz der großen Herausforderung
vor denen wir stehen der Fall sein und
das zweite ist dass wir die rechtlichen
Rahmenbedingungen über die wir eben
schon gesprochen haben so verbessern
dass das Geld auch ausgegeben werden
kann und wir vorankommen mit den
Planungen und den Investitionen die in
diesem Bereich notwendig sind ein Teil
der Infrastruktur ist privat das wissen
wir auch
etwa wenn es unsere Stromnetz geht oder
das Gasnetz oder
verschiedene andere Netze die für uns
eine Rolle spielen Telekommunikation
etwa und da müssen wir durch richtige
Gesetze dafür Sorge tragen dass das auch
eine erstklassige Versorgung wird ich
glaube dass die vielen
weißen Flecken im Bereich des Mobilfunks
zum Beispiel nicht akzeptabel sind und
auch wenn es private Anwender bieter
sind müssen sie Deutschland gut
versorgen das ist mit der privaten
Investition in dieser Frage auch als
Verpflichtung verbunden
möchten Sie eine Nachfrage stellen bitte
sehen
ja besten Dank mein Kollege von der FDP
ist bereits auf die
planungsbeschleunigung eingegangen und
wir alle wissen dass wir für eine
erfolgreiche Infrastrukturpolitik der
Zukunft und die planungsbeschleunigung
insbesondere einen gutes Zusammenspiel
brauchen zwischen Kommunen Ländern und
dem Mond und dem Bund und deshalb meine
Nachfrage wie die gedenken Sie dieses
Zusammenspiel dieses Zusammenwirken der
Ebenen zu befördern
indem man sich unter hakt das wird nicht
anders gehen können indem wir zur
Verfügung stellen was wir an Fähigkeiten
haben ein Bereich der Planung haben wir
übernommen was die Bundesfernstraßen
betrifft aber es wird insgesamt um enge
Kooperationen gehen und dass das ein
alltägliche Praxis wird wir sind
jedenfalls dazu bereit
der Kollege Lucas stellte zunächst Frage
bitte schön
frau Präsidentin der Bundeskanzler
vielen Dank ich möchte eine Frage zu
Wohnungsbaupolitik stellen die Ampel hat
sich in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen 400.000 Wohnungen im Jahr zu
bauen das sind 1,6 Millionen Wohnungen
in der Legislaturperiode das ist auch
wichtig und auch notwendig weil wir
sehen dass gerade in den großen Städten
die Schlangen bei den
Wohnungsbesichtigungen über länger
werden die Mieten steigen es fehlt eine
Bezahlbarkeit des Bodens deswegen
brauchen wir diesen Neubau nun stellen
wir aber fest und das sagen alle
Experten dass dieses Ziel nicht einmal
zur Hälfte erfüllt werden wird alle
sagen das zeigen die Schlagzeilen der
letzten Tage es werden wahrscheinlich
nicht 100.000 Wohnungen gebaut werden
sondern einen letzten Jahr
wahrscheinlich nur 280 in diesem Jahr
nur 250 und so weiter also es werden
deutlich weniger Wohnung gebaut werden
was sagen Sie jetzt diesen Menschen die
in den Schlangen bei den
Wohnungsbesichtigungen stehen und am
Ende keine bezahlbare Wohnung haben
wieso ihre bauministerin und ihre
Bundesregierung dieses so wichtige Ziel
für unser Land nicht erreicht
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage und ich will
ihnen erstmal bestätigen dass das ein
zentrales Ziel ist dass wir
kontinuierlich die Bauleistungen in
Deutschland nach oben treiben damit dann
regelmäßig 400.000 Wohnungen gebaut
werden dass wir das können kann man
daran sehen dass wenn man
ich glaube ganz genaue verhaften sich
mal nicht auf die Zahl aber West- und
aus zusammenrechnet 1972 wer etwa
800.000 Wohnungen gebaut haben ist also
keine
unerfüllbare Aufgabe aber das bedeutet
dass die Unternehmen dass diejenigen die
investieren und dass die die stetige
Gemeinden alle anderen diese Perspektive
auch so im Blick haben dass sie
langfristige Investitionen zur
Ausweitung ihrer Kapazitäten treffen
damit diese Zielsetzung auch erfüllt
werden können und das versuchen wir auch
zu unterstützen mit dem Bündnis für das
Wohnen und den Verabredungen die dort
getroffen worden sind wo sehr sehr viele
ganz im Einzelnen beschriebene
Beschwerden ist das Bauens abgebaut
werden und daran arbeiten wir jetzt die
alle einen nach dem anderen in aus dem
Tempo zu beseitigen gleichzeitig
brauchen wir eine Vereinheitlichung wenn
wir seriell bauen wollen was übrigens
nicht Platte heißt wie es von einigen
immer behauptet wird aber wenn wir
seriell bauen wollen also die
Grundstruktur öfter mal als die gleiche
haben dann bedeutet das auch dass man
mit dem einmal irgendwo in Deutschland
genehmigten
Haus auch vielleicht anderswo noch
realisieren kann ob man als Eckhaus als
Mittelhaus oder als als als einzelnes
Objekt als Turmhaus wenn es um
mehrfamilienwohnungen geht und diesen
Fortschritt den müssen wir unbedingt
erreichen weil das eine Verbesserung
bedeutet für viele Unternehmen die sich
dann darauf verlassen können dass sie
mit der Grundstruktur die sich schon mal
genehmigt bekommen haben auch an anderen
Stellen in Deutschland bauen können und
meinen Eindruck ist das würde auch dazu
führen dass es erhebliche
Kostenreduktionen gibt dann eine
erheblicher Teil der Kosten des
Wohnungsbau sind mit dem
Planungsunternehmen Prozessen verknüpft
meine Nachfrage bitte schön
der Bundeskanzler sie haben zwei
wichtige Punkte angesprochen zum einen
die Verlässlichkeit von
Förderbedingungen damit die
Bauwirtschaft Kapazitäten aufbauen kann
zum anderen das Bündnis für bezahlbaren
Wohnraum wir erklären sich dann aber
dass die Wohnungswirtschaft also die
Unternehmen die am Ende die Wohnung
schaffen müssen sagen dass sie ihre
Projekte jetzt deswegen stornieren
müssen weil diese Bundesregierung die
Förderung für den Neubau radikal gekappt
hat zusammengestrichen hat dass die
Wirtschaftlichkeit der Projekte nicht
mehr gegeben ist und deswegen nicht mehr
bezahlbar gebaut werden kann und wieso
erklären sie sich wenn das von ihnen so
hoch gelobte Bündnisse bezahlbaren
Wohnraum nur sechs Wochen nachdem sie
mit der bauministerin die Ergebnisse
präsentiert haben ist ein alarmierenden
Weckruf auf sehr Immobilienwirtschaft
gegeben hat man brauche jetzt einen
neuen entschieden den politischen
Kraftakt weil das bisherige nicht
ausreicht wie erklären sich das zunächst
haben wir einen großen Kraftwerk
vorgenommen indem wir die Mittel für den
geförderten Wohnungsbau erheblich
ausgeweitet haben das ist auch ganz ganz
zentral weil dann bezahlbare Wohnung auf
dem Wohnungsmarkt neu entstehen und
vielleicht darf ich Ihnen diese
statistische Besonderheit sagen in
manchen Städten in Deutschland wenn man
da genauer hinschaut sind die Hälfte der
Mietwohnung die es gibt irgendwann mal
als geförderte Wohnung entstanden
zwischen
1919 und heute und das ist ein Hinweis
darauf dass es da eine lange Tradition
des geförderten Wohnungsbaus für
bezahlbare Wohnungen gibt und dass das
bis heute die Struktur unserer Städte
und die Bezahlbarkeit des
wohnraumangebotes prägt eine gute Sache
also und auch gut dass wir das neu
ausgeweitet haben bei den förderregime
die wir bisher hatten waren sehr viele
die am Ende unterschiedslos auch die
Häuser und Wohnungen gefördert haben von
Leuten die Kraft ihrer Finanzen auch
ohne die Förderung den Wohnungsbau
errichtet hätten und entweder sehr sehr
teure Mieten die nur für einige zahlbar
sind akzeptiert hätten oder aber eben
sehr hohe Preise für den Erwerb eine
Eigentumswohnung oder eines
Einfamilienhaus zum Beispiel und deshalb
ist es schon richtig die Fokussierung
darauf zu nehmen dann aber mit der
Unterstützung im Bereich der Programme
die dkfw auf den Weg bringt etwas dafür
zu tun dass Wohnungsbau vorangebracht
werden kann auch außerhalb des sozialen
Wohnungsbaus und das auch Familien nicht
alleine gelassen werden das ist das
vielleicht ist das jetzt ganz wichtig
dass die
fehlorientierung jetzt konzentriert
worden ist auf das was am Ende zu einer
Entlastung auf dem Wohnungsmarkt
beiträgt und ich hoffe dass das Tempo
dann auch hinterher zieht jetzt werden
einige ihre Projekte umplanen müssen und
dann wird es vielleicht nicht
9000 12.000 Euro pro Quadratmeter
Eigentumswohnung sondern eine bezahlbare
Wohnung das wäre jetzt aber für
Deutschland insgesamt auch kein so
großes Problem
möchten Sie eine weitere Nachfrage
stellen das ist nicht der Fall dann ist
die nächste Frage okay entschuldigung
habe ich nicht gesehen dann bitteschön
frau Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler sie
haben gerade von viel Allokationen
gesprochen auf der anderen Seite haben
Sie als Bundesfinanzminister in der
letzten Periode 10 Milliarden Euro für
den
Wohnungseigentums Erwerb für Familien
zur Verfügung gestellt das
Durchschnittseinkommen 45000 €, also
weiß Gott kein Reichtum jetzt stellen
für den sie für den
Wohnungseigentums Erwerb in dieser
Regierung in 10 Jahren 3,5 Milliarden
lediglich zur Verfügung glauben Sie
wirklich dass sie damit Familien ein
Zuhause bieten können glauben Sie
wirklich das Familien damit den Traum
von den vier Wänden sich verwirklichen
können
sehr wohl sind die Programme sehr
speziell zugerichtet und das will ich
ausgerichtet auf die Bedarfe und
Bedürfnisse allerdings gibt es eine
Besonderheit die wahrscheinlich ein
notwendige Verbesserung von der
Situation ist es ist an der höhere
Konzentration auf den Neubau von
bezahlbaren auch Einfamilienhäusern die
Familien sich zum Beispiel kaufen wollen
errichtet worden weil wir erreichen
wollen dass die Gesamtmenge der Wohnung
mehr wird
vielen Dank dann ist die nächste Frage
die Kollegin Nina stark
frau Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler wir
haben uns als Ampelkoalition vorgenommen
jedes Kind mit guten Startchancen ins
Leben auszurüsten dafür ist meiner
Meinung nach und unserer Meinung nach
die Kinder Grundsicherung ein zentrales
Projekt dieser Koalition wir wissen es
ist von enormer Bedeutung in Deutschland
wächst jedes fünfte Kind in Armut auf in
Ballungsräumen hier in Berlin vor der
Haustür beispielsweise ist das noch viel
extremer deswegen meine Frage an Sie
Herr Bundeskanzler wie können diese
Kindergrundsicherung nur umsetzen
erfolgreich gemeinsam als Koalition
gemeinsam mit der Zivilgesellschaft
welche Rolle sehen Sie für diese
Kindergrundsicherung wie zentral halten
Sie dieses Projekt und welche Rolle
glauben sie spielt dabei Digitalisierung
schönen Dank in der Tat die
Kindergrundsicherung
ist ein großes Vorhaben der
Bundesregierung und aller sie tragenden
Parteien und wir sind dabei die
Diskussion jetzt so voranzutreiben dass
wir sie rechtzeitig gesetzt werden
lassen können
man kann sehen dass wir ja schon einen
großen Fortschritt gemacht haben der ist
vielleicht nicht für jeden für Sie
sicher aber nicht für jeden so
wahrnehmbar geworden aber ich will das
sagen mit der Anhebung des Kindergeldes
für das erste zweite und dritte Kind auf
250 Euro was eine riesige Entlastung für
Familien bedeutet mit der
Anhebung des
Zuschlags für erwerbstätige Eltern mit
Kindern ebenfalls auf 250 Euro ist eine
große Entlastung für familienverbunden
und im übrigen gerade für wegen des
zweiten Teils Familie mit geringsten
Einkommen das ist ein ganz ganz guter
Fortschritt und das ist die Basis dafür
dass wir uns jetzt bei dem
Reformvorhaben sehr genau auch mit
Fragen der technischen Umsetzbarkeit
beschäftigen können deshalb geht es
darum eine Reform zu machen die so
einfach und verständlich ist dass alle
die Verbesserung die damit für Sie
verbunden sind erkennen
und eine Reform auf den Weg zu bringen
die so ist
dass nicht die Tatsache dass man sich
damit nicht auskennt Leistung die wir
bewusst für Erwerbstätige Familien zum
Beispiel mit geringen Einkommen
bereitstellen nicht in Anspruch genommen
werden das ist ja ein Phänomen mit dem
wir heute
herausgefordert sind und deshalb wird
auch die Frage dass das gesetzgeberisch
so entwickelt wird dass es auch einfach
digitalisiert werden kann und einfach
genutzt werden kann eine zentrale Rolle
spielen das ist also sowohl in der Frage
der technischen Umsetzung der Innovation
in der Verwaltungspraxis als auch was
das Gesamtgefüge betrifft ein sehr
ehrgeiziges Vorhaben aber wir wollen das
gut hinkriegen
haben sie noch eine Nachfrage bitte sehr
haben sie nicht vielen Dank dann beende
ich mit einer Minute überziehen die
Befragung Herr Bundeskanzler vielen Dank
und
ich rufe auch den Tagesordnungspunkt
Nummer zwei die Befragung der
Damen und da sind wir wieder hier im
Studio die Befragung der Bundesregierung
das ist das eine die
Bundespressekonferenz ist jetzt das
andere da geht es um das Thema die
Zukunft der Wirtschaft der
bundeswirtschaft